[Music]
it's
gone you both know what's at stake
here there isn't much Road left take the
bloody
shot the first ever time I've seen a
bomb film on IMAX amazing wow opening
sequence Bond everything you see is just
bond is action going on and you see a
fantastic experience your heart's
bracing feels more real cuz you have to
look around the sound the pinch quality
at one point the screen will just expand
and then the screen just goes boom
you're like yes motorbikes across the
top of the bazaar mountains valleys R of
a round of applause at certain points
certain Bond moments there was an actual
squeal when that happened when you got
director's quality like deacons behind
the camera and Sam men is directing it
with a Stella cast you got see it just
feels like more of an experience and you
you can't get it anywhere else it blew
me away it's amazing
[Music]
um